let's jump to this story we got from
Yahoo news it's actually syndicated from
the National Review San Francisco
reparations committee chairman admits no
math formula behind five million dollar
payout plan that's right they're going
to write a five million dollar check to
each black resident and they didn't use
a mathematical formula to determine that
they just decided that's that's the
number I guess plus like a lifetime
guarantee of Revenue but uh although
you're just mentioning that people build
communities and personalities around
Grievances and I have to wonder if one
of the reasons we're never actually
going to see reparations is because
these political groups need it as as a
political culture as a tool to win power
yeah no I agree
this plan is going to cost billions of
dollars San Francisco it's like I think
twice the budget of like the city budget
like they cannot afford it and they're
like it doesn't matter we'll just say
yes and figure it out later it's crazy
that they that like they haven't figured
it out yet that they are political pawns
until the end of time if they keep
saying well we're going to give you this
because you're black we're going to give
you this if your ancestors were slaves
it's like what if you're at a certain
what if your ancestors were slave owners
do you
I don't know my family came over later
so don't look at me because Angela Davis
is descended from the Mayflower I love
this story but I mean it's like look a
lot of people on the right are like
Angela Davis she's like she's like a
black panther right she was yeah she
committed communist the Communist Party
in America was not radical enough for
her so she quit but like the the thing
is you know these people like y'all do
realize the reason she's descended from
people from the mayflowers not because
she's like the heir to the Mayflower
family it's because the slave owners
probably raped her ancestors and like
had kids it wasn't like you know a
daughter in the Mayflower flower family
fell in love with a black man and they
decided to defy the law and
miscegenation and have kids it was
probably a slave woman being raped by a
slave owner or something like that so
it's like it's not like you know when
when people are making fun of her I'm
like ah it's kind of a bad thing but my
question then becomes she's still the
descendants of slave owners right
like how does that work well it doesn't
matter because they'll still claim that
well your skin color still made it so
that the social you know the the social
interactions you know you were still
discriminated against even though these
were your descendants but yeah it does
go back to that that community of of
victimhood and you could see it on her
face when she was told oh your ancestors
came on the Mayflower she was like oh no
this is too much like this is horrible
it's like you should probably get a get
a 23andMe or an ancestry.com before you
start making your entire career and your
entire personality predicated on the
idea that you were a victim to be fair
she was doing this in the 60s this was a
little before they they sequenced the
genome
um I just want to say that this is
probably Scott Adams approved
the reparations yeah because black
people are gonna go like mad to San
Francisco
um Scott Adams had in that video where
they called him racist he said he was in
favor of affirmative action and
diversity programs and stuff like that
so it's just like they really did cut
the context of what she was saying
because it was like I support these
things like you know I I yeah but anyway
well the San Francisco one is crazy
because there are qualifications can't
just be anyone right so you have to have
been in the city between uh 1940 and
1996. or you have to be it have been
like 96 yeah if you've been if you were
born between 1940 and 1986 or wasn't
there for at least 13 years if you've
migrated there from a different country
between 1940 and 1996 you also like can
have been personally affected I'm not
sure I couldn't get an explanation out
of the document I read because they
proposed this a couple months ago and at
the time
this this program's gonna cost 50
billion dollars so what I think is crazy
is they're saying like a couple of the
other things like if you've been
affected by the War on Drugs you have
you meet one of the two uh of eight
criteria that need to I gotta compromise
take the 50 billion dollars from one of
these big tech companies Facebook or
something take 50 billion 50 billion
from them and then give out reparations
I would I would accept those terms no it
will never end though they'll get
reparations and it's it's never ending
yeah I mean my point though is I don't
care it destroys Facebook yeah so you
know it's like whatever no this makes me
think okay oh no we got to get more
vibrations oh what's what's that Google
oh geez he's gonna have to take money
from you next oh what's that Pfizer but
maybe they should right because if
you're saying like uh Black Americans in
San Francisco have been
disproportionately affected by a lot of
things and they now can't afford housing
here well who drove up housing in San
Francisco San Francisco's already
expensive but tech industry did so maybe
Google and Facebook should contribute to
this fund yeah but what I think is crazy
is that they're saying like yeah we'll
say yes because they know they'll
possibly get elected off of it it's
never gonna happen there's no way they
have 50 billion dollars to fund this
program they're just going to say but
we're the ones who voted in favor of
reparation so elect me again I mean you
guys bring up interesting points but you
fail to consider what these Tech
Engineers will eat for lunch if they
give away all this money how will they
get their steak lunches how will they
get their wine untapped him that is true
come on I know that that keeps me up at
night sometimes we'll have to pay them
I'm imagining some 22 year old fresh out
of college you know crying because the
wine on tap stopped running
uh I think that really we shouldn't harm
the tech industry we should just Rob all
of Middle America to pay for San
Francisco's reparation program
yeah no I uh so you agree there's a lot
going on here sorry uh yeah no this
reminds me I went I did a man on the
street in San Francisco a couple months
back when they were doing their
reparations program quote unquote for
Trans people in San Francisco that said
if you're trans you were negatively
affected by the social ills and the
discrimination against transgenders and
so they were giving out money what was
it it was like thirteen hundred dollars
a month for up to 18 months you're
getting paid just to be you yeah the
weirdest thing about the reparations in
California is that California was never
a slave state yeah it's like I don't
understand what is California paying for
the
the most sorry
and it can't happen so if you're a black
American in San Francisco who really
thinks like maybe I will make some money
off of this like you're being lied to
and they're okay with that because it
scores them essentially cheap political
points five million dollars per person I
mean
if you could identify as trans can I
identify as black and move to San
Francisco yes you have to it says here
you have to have identified as black or
African-American on public documents for
at least 10 years so like even if you're
white
Rachel dolezal is like I'm ready here we
go I mean hold on what if what if what
if she is ascendant of slaves
you know what I mean like Angela Davis
is descendant of the is a descendant of
the Mayflower but pilgrims or whatever
or colonists or whatever
I feel like if anyone Rachel dolezal
might be descended of uh Irish
indentured servants but I doubt that she
is affected by the slave trade but I'm
not saying necessarily her I'm saying
that there's going to be some white dude
with blonde hair and blue eyes who pulls
out as 23 in me and it's like 2.7
percent black and he's like yep there's
like you know old old great great great
great grandma and you know for sure
that's right the first African-American
I cannot wait for Tariq nasheed's take
on this because you you do know about
his whole thing about the fba's the
foundational black Americans uh you know
trick machine yeah so yeah he he's like
a black nationalist guy yeah yeah and he
rails against the non-fba so essentially
if you weren't a foundational black
American if you weren't some of the
first slaves then he gets mad at these
Africans and these other black people
that came over later or just recently
and they say that they're entitled to
these reparations
um and he goes hard on them so I'm
really I'm looking forward to his his
take on this racism is so profitable
racist he's racist against other black
people he is so I got an idea because uh
people I'm not totally against this
point though we're gonna do reparations
I kind of get what he's saying people
are super chatting about how they're
working hard and working in factories
and all that stuff here's my plan all
right
you know in the future if I ever end up
finding myself in office I'll propose a
bill or maybe when I go talk to Matt
Gates I'll be like hey make this bill
that uh if you work in a non-labor job
you got to pay double the taxes and that
goes to the people who actually do work
there you go problem solved so like if
you work at a university well you know
we're going to take an extra you know 15
of your paycheck and it's going to go
pay a factory worker salary I like that
it's the least we could do to help the
workers right you're not oppose the
workers do you it's an only fans tax
right let's take let's take 30 out of
the only fans models and give them to
their stock Brokers pay Traders uh
universities professors feminists dance
theorists tax on all of that yeah
government bureaucrats yeah and then
anybody who actually makes stuff they
get a bonus in their salary supplemental
income that's well that's socialism I
mean right they agree with it or maybe
we should just make everyone complete
two years of like a skill trade before
they can enter a four-year University
like maybe you should have to work with
your hands before you pursue your degree
I think every every gender studies
degree should have at least
they're forced to break rocks yeah
yeah or just Shadow like a plumber I
just love it there was a there was a
meme of some like leftist being like I
can't wait till we make them you know
break rocks so that they can figure out
what what a real day's uh real day of
hard work feels like and it's just like
you don't work what what are you talking
about who are you talking about the dude
who works in a factory driving a
forklift all day and is covering sweat
and the guy works on a petroleum rig
drenched in oil and high chance at Death
Do you ever see those uh videos on
Instagram or Tick Tock where it's like a
day in my life as a consultant I woke up
at 9 30 and I put on my sweatsuit and
then I went to my desk to start working
and like seemed perfectly Pleasant have
a good time but I really want like a
commercial electrician the electrician
to make one oh I woke up at 3am and
commuted to work and then you know I
wired and I had to cut all this stuff
like I carried got into an argument with
a client then it's like him filming a
guy yelling at him yeah it's just them
going to seven meetings a day what do
you need to go to a meeting for like do
you think Farmers like have meetings
every morning for three hours being the
guy in the oil rig is like yeah I went
to four meetings today I'll Circle back
to it it's fine yeah look at how many
people Twitter fired in the past six
months oh man and Twitter essentially
operates the same and they fired
thousands of people now think about that
at every University in America
everything tech company every startup
everybody that could convince uh uh
someone with some money that they they
give me money and I'll make your money
into a tech giant or whatever
um they that's they get funding and they
load it up with with all their friends
who are doing nothing at all thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time